bonjour vous êtes prêts à vous battre
madame
vous êtes prêtes à vous battre
vous avez votre kimono
vous voulez mon numéro c'est ça
je suis déjà casé madame je vous en
couple amoureux
ça va ça fait pas trop mal
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça manquait de volume sur les côtés
parfait on essaye OK
ça réveille
mais oui merci
qu'est-ce que tu préfères dans le métier
d'actrice
préparer un personnage
[Applaudissements]
quel est son rêve absolu rêve concret ou
un rêve un peu fou parce que rêve ça
veut rien concret concret
acheter ma boîte mais tu l'as dit 10
fois
tu me foutrais dehors
est-ce que ça te ferait plaisir ou ça te
ferait envie qu'on aille
j'ai pas fini la phrase viens ici
m'écouter
est-ce que ça te ferait plaisir qu'on
aille ce à contrôler ah si
qu'on aille se promener
oui c'est bon tu peux t'exciter là c'est
bon